[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy find practical advice
you can use in your everyday life hi I'm
Dan haaste I'm joined by my co-host Dr
Greg Sadler and today we're going to
talk about waiting back into the deep
end of
AI and if you don't know what that a
means we'll we'll explain it shortly I
do want to say this is going to be our
fifth show where we've considered aita
posts from Reddit and there is a lot of
practical advice that we can call out of
these but I think a lot of it is don't
be like these people what do you think
Dan yeah a lot of times there's some A's
uh going around so so we can explain
what aita is so the a-hole is the um the
way that it is is described and it's
people asking um for advice from you
know hopefully independent third parties
um on this website Reddit if their
situation who in that situation is
a-hole is it them is it someone else or
no one's the a-hole or everyone's the
a-hole yeah I think sometimes it's
labeled everybody sucks right as the
fourth option and these are actually
really quite good I I've considered
using these in my ethics classes as case
studies because they're taken as far as
we know from real life and people are
genuinely confused wondering whether
they did the right thing a lot of times
people are second guessing themselves or
they've been told by other people that
they're a jerk and they're trying to
solicit some feedback from other people
I often see a lot of good analysis in
the comments um what is that your
experience with these you think the the
commenters are pretty on point well I
guess usually the ones that are voted
are pretty good um there if you go down
into the go by like sort by cont
controversial then you get some
interesting things but yeah it's kind of
a wisdom of the crowds like we're all
you know social beings um and that we
have a lifetime of like inferences of
how not to you know other people um and
so usually the cream Rises to the crop
or to the top there um but it's it's fun
um and I guess I love these episodes in
part because it allows us to really Flex
our different like uh ethical systems um
and so like oh maybe this is Con and
maybe this is um you deontological what
what what system would work best for
this particular thing or we could go
through a number of different systems
and sometimes you'll get conflicting
answers based on those conflicting
systems that's true you know one of the
things I really like about them is that
they are taken from like ordinary life
so there's a lot of family situations as
we're going to see there's a lot of
things having to do with uh school or
the workplace um there's always a lot of
things having to do with family events
like parties or weddings so we've got uh
quite a slate I don't know if we'll
actually get to every single case that
we thought was interesting uh what do
you think should we Ju Just Jump Right
In absolutely let just go for it okay so
do you want to read the first one or do
you want me to um sure I'll go for it
okay this is a a a preemptive am I the
a-hole um it says will I be the a-hole
for getting a cat when my husband
doesn't want one uh I a 40-year-old
female and my husband Anthony
uh 40-year-old male are having a
disagreement without getting a cat we
have two children one adult daughter 21
and soon to be teen 12 we also have an
adult daughter's fiance living with us
Paul 22 male Ive had cats my whole life
and our last cat of 14 years died about
5 years ago a and I agreed to wait a
little while before getting a new pet I
work full-time and the sole source of
income and I just finished getting my
master's degree I have been a
stay-at-home parent for the last 10
years I have wanted to get a new cat for
about 3 years but put it off due to
school I stated that I would like to get
a cat when I am done with school as a
reward for myself for theom
accomplishment he is strongly against
getting a pet as he said he doesn't want
to take care of it that they are
expensive and will take frequent weekend
trips in the summer Fridays to Saturday
sometimes we have to leave on Thursday
night if I'm not on call I've been very
sad about not getting a cat it have been
the longest amount of time I've had been
without one I feel like the perk of a
cat is that they are so independent so I
do the grocery shopping and 90 5% of the
cooking we keep our houses relatively
tidy so our housework is not too
overwhelming he does all the outdoor
duties I feel like I do a lot and don't
ask for anything I have all my friends
telling me to just get the cat as well
as rest of the people in the house his
sister and mother I'm trying to be
respectful of his wishes but I'm hurt
that he is so comfortable with how sad
I'm about his refusal to get a cat and I
have told him this he said that if I
bring a cat home he'll get rid of it
while I'm at work which is so hurtful
and the reason I haven't done it one I
wanted every time I bring it up he gets
frustrated and angry at me I recently
had someone offer me a cat that they
can't have I want it so bad will I be
the a-hole if I just wi and got the cat
this is one of those cases where you're
tempted to say get the cat ditch the guy
you
know very simple solution there's a lot
of things in here that seem like red
flags to me you know um if he has been a
stay-at-home parent for the last 10
years it doesn't seem like he does an
awful lot around the place for somebody
who is um you know whose spouse is is
the the bread winner and you know the
saying that um if she brings a cat home
he'll get rid of it that's to me a very
aggressive move on his part you know
maybe it's hyperbolic maybe there's more
to the story there but that seems like a
complete jerk move to
me yeah I guess that I also really
picked up on the whole like I'll get rid
of it um but I guess this is two people
make
moves for like a unilateral decision
it's like if you do this unilaterally
then I'm going to do this like
unilaterally um but at the expense of of
of an animal you know oh yeah um I guess
then the main thing here is like why is
it so difficult to like try to meet the
needs of your partner um or at least the
desires of this um yeah a lot of this
stuff is like kind of like frosting it's
not the meat of the thing at all it's
it's the autra mons um and so really
it's like okay
why I don't understand why this is such
a hard ask for him and it seems like
he's unwilling to actually have that
deep conversation especially because
like his main objection seems to be that
um they might not be able to go on long
trips whereas like most cats are
independent like maybe for the first bit
like you got got a especially if you get
a young cat but if you got like a
shelter cat they're usually pretty dang
independent you know he also says that
it's expensive which is quite true I
mean vet bills and you know food and
litter and stuff like that but I mean
they've got kids and kids are way more
expensive than than a cat is and he's
not contributing anything to the to the
household finances as far as I can tell
so why is I mean why does he even have a
an opinion on on expense you know what
is he he's the accountant budget you
know doing all the budgeting and
balancing the books you know that seems
a little off to
me yeah and
like with the the amount of like Tech
that is to like deal with C like the
main thing is to clean the litter box
there's literally robotic litter boxes
nowadays oh true yeah um or I've also
found like pellets to be really great
like these wood pellets that just like
it makes like the whole uh you know
kitty litter like seem like a a an old
world
technology you know the other thing that
really struck me about this one is um
she says I'm hurt that he's so
comfortable with how sad I am about his
refusal to get a cat and so you know if
you're if you're in a committed
relationship and they're married right
and they have they have uh two children
um and you're going to be okay longterm
term with standing in the way of your
spouse's clearly expressed desires that
have been on hold for a long time and
you're fine with them feeling you know
whatever it is sad anxious angry uh pick
whatever emotion you want that's a sign
there's something really wrong there in
my
view right that that is also very like a
big old red plague oh I guess I would
say get some marriage counseling I don't
know
who's yeah I also don't know like what
his hang up is it feels like there's not
enough information for me to like okay
definitively say if anyone is
particularly the a-hole or will be the
a-hole um I think he is an a-hole um
just going from what we've got
here and it's it's also you know it's
not just her it's um oh all the friends
all of her friends and the rest of the
people in the house his sister and
mother so you know he's he's uh really
standing out by his refusal here I'd say
but she's definitely the aole yeah um
she's not and one of the the things that
like you get a cat as long as this cat
is not like a terar they're they're very
lovable like yeah he's probably going to
like it if they've had cats in the past
maybe he had a problem with their cat in
the past again we like you pointed out
we don't have enough information here so
yeah yeah um hey uh you want to hit this
next one here sure am I the a-hole for
cussing out my son's math teacher when
my older son was going to high school
they had an amazing math teacher now she
unfortunately retired in the school as a
new teacher that is much worse my
16-year-old male son I guess that kind
of makes sense uh started having issues
with math his grades dropped
significantly his teacher called me in
to basically tell me that my son isn't
doing well in class I contacted another
parent and it turns out he's not the
only kid with this issue basically the
teacher is so incompetent that she
doesn't even try to explain complicated
exercises to the students she just hopes
they will somehow get it and gives them
loads of homework that they don't even
understand an example she gave them a
test with really complex cube root
equations even though she only briefly
explained the square roots so when she
called me in she basically told me that
I should have explained that at home I
was very pissed because it's the teacher
duty to explain things not mine I have
two kids one of whom is chronically ill
and I have a full-time job on top of
that my kids are fed and clothed and
well- raised and being their math
teacher isn't my responsibility so I
said I don't expect you to feed and
clothe my kid why the F do you expect me
to teach him I manage my
responsibilities completely fine can you
manage yours for effan once she said I
was behaving inappropriately and
threatened to report me to CPS I said
good effing luck and left she told the
school principal about it and he
contacted me saying I verbally assaulted
the teacher so um what do you think is
she an a-hole for cussing out her her
son's math teacher I probably I I I'd
say
that everyone's aole oh yeah yeah maybe
not the principal I don't know what like
the principal is doing or what they know
exactly but um yeah yeah I feel like um
both the teacher if this is true from
what we read um is delinquent in their
duties as well
as that um the mother um didn't have to
curse at her she could have said the
important thing without getting to the
cursing I guess I feel like she let her
the anger in the situation um control
her more than it ought yeah I I can
understand that uh reaction on her part
it is things will work better if you
don't swear at people but I also think
that this like you know the teacher
threatening to report her to CPS if that
indeed happened that's way over the top
that's that's a super defensive move and
it's it's a power
play um I don't know if say I mean it'd
be different if she was like f you f you
f you instead she's saying um why the F
do you expect me to teach him can you
manage yours for f and once and then she
said good effing luck so it's not as if
she's swearing directly at her calling
her names or something right she's using
the f word as a emphasizer it seems to
me so I don't I don't think that's
verbally assaulting somebody oh I I
don't agree like that's verbally
assaulting but I also feel like you know
if you actually want to get like do you
want to be angry and and do the things
that anger is going to tell you to do or
do you want to actually get results yeah
and that's not productive in the second
uh desire there yeah so maybe she's a
semi a-hole not not a full a-hole and
the teacher is an a-hole you know for
being especially for that CPS comment
yeah well but I mean also if she's in
over her head she should be seeking out
a mentor she should be like figuring out
how to do the the math stuff that she's
supposed to be teaching the kids how to
do
you right I mean if I was an English
teacher and I had a small vocabulary I
think I'd get myself one of those desk
calendars that has you know vocabulary
words throughout the year and I'd expand
it you know if I wasn't quite sure how
to do cube roots maybe I'd brush up on
that right hey you only got to be a week
ahead of your
students so this is a bit of a
digression that's what one of my friends
and colleagues actually says as a
college professor you know and he's been
doing it you know I don't know 30 years
or so and he's like that's all you got
to do stay a week ahead and you're just
fine
all right should we move on to the next
one yeah um so uh am I the aole for
cutting off internet after asking my
roommates to give me their share of the
bill the house I live in doesn't have
internet included with the rent and so
it's on the tenants to get their own
service and put to pay for it I'm fine
with this Arrangement and REM roommates
have been fine with it for the last 3
years there's three of us living in the
house the internet bill is my name and I
am sure to pay it each month and my
roommates pay their 3D if the bill uh of
the bill I guess I let them pay
when they are get around to it each
month I have never had a problem with
this as long as they pay me um this
month they still haven't paid me so I
asked them about it they said that they
aren't going to pay since the bill is
not on their name I told them that if
they don't pay me by the end of the week
I will cut off the internet access I
gave them the weekend a pay me and
nothing I texted both of them on Monday
morning after asking them to pay me or
be counting off their access and
changing the password they haven't
responded so I changed the password and
now I'm getting text from both them
saying that I am such an a-hole I am not
going to give them the new password
until they pay me the roommates are
a-holes yeah that's that's cut and dry
that that's you know contractualism you
want to like this seems perfectly
reasonable behavior on his part to me uh
he he gave them more than enough time
exactly yeah he uh so I I see in this
that he gave them basically two notices
and they blew them off each
time um pay him by the end of the week
gave them the weekend to pay text them I
think three times he actually said hey
you gotta you got to pay me and they've
been doing it for three years
so you know I know maybe there's
something something weird going on here
that we're missing or yeah if this is
all it is then yeah it's pretty cut and
dry uh and if it's not that there's some
other like conflict that's going on like
maybe there's like interpersonal or
romantic issues or or some other issue
within the living Arrangement that is
off yeah you know like you know
sometimes a um a tenant will refuse to
pay their landlord because they haven't
like fixed the lights or something what
whatever is the issue because you're not
providing that service but like uh I I
don't we don't know
but it's yeah there's nothing in this
that suggests that that's the case to me
yeah I mean they and it's weird that
they
say it's not in their name so we're not
going to pay it I mean they've been
doing it that entire time so why why
that shift we we just don't know right
right that's why it seems odd yeah I
mean I think this is one of those cases
that we can generalize and we can say
listen if there's something that one
person is footing the bill for and
you've made an arrangement you got to
stick to the arrangement and if you
don't they're perfectly within their
rights to say okay you don't get that
service it could be like the water bill
it could be cable it could be you know I
don't know a magazine subscription of
people will indeed you know do that
anymore today I I don't know what sir
what what are magazines that you speak
of I've seen them people still send them
out to us um it's weird too because uh
we also get these massive there's a
total digression these massive oine
cataloges that are you know super glossy
they weigh like I don't know like three4
lbs and neither my wife or I are ever
going to order anything out of that you
know but they and they just keep sending
them they just keep wasting all that
money and paper and ink on that um
anyway back to this they make great fire
starters I you know I I sure I'm sure
they do but I think that there's a lot
of chemicals in that paper and I don't
know it would be good for anybody in the
room to be exposed to that much of it
but they are probably pretty flammable
yeah uh so the next one there okay am I
the a-hole for refusing to have a fully
childfree
wedding I recently proposed to my
long-term girlfriend and we're planning
for a wedding in summer next year
everything is in still very early stages
my fiance has expressed that she wants a
child-free wedding which I am all down
for but I want to make one exception my
15-year-old son I had him from a
previous relationship and we have evenly
split custody of him until now my fiance
has gotten along great with him we've
had days out as a family she's gone to
see his games he plays ice hockey and
she's even taken him out on fundays just
the two of them I brought up that I
wanted to make an exception to the no
kids rule for my son she shot the idea
down straight away and said she didn't
want anyone under 16 there and she
doesn't want to feel like she or anyone
else has to babysit on her special day I
told her that no one would have to
babysit him he's 15 she knows he's well
behaved and a generally quiet kid so
then she changed her reasoning and asked
why I wanted my old family in life on
the day I was supposed to be making a
commitment to her and her new family I
told her while I will be making a
commitment to her my son will still be
very much my son and my family she then
equated it to wanting my ex at our
wedding which I do not and have never
asked I told her that I don't care about
the Aesthetics of the wedding she can
pick everything else the food the
aesthetic the music the dress but all I
want is my family at my wedding my
parents my sisters and my son that is my
only ultimatum when it comes to our
wedding she started calling me
controlling by giving me an ultimatum
and said I had initially agreed to a
child-free wedding and now I'm
gaslighting her I said we can have a
mainly child-free wedding but with this
one exception and expectation that
guests can't even complain about being
unfair since the only child is the son
of the groom she called me a jerk and is
now not talking to me I really think
this is a reasonable want but maybe I'm
not seeing something so am I the
a-hole what do you think is he the
a-hole
no all right
so so we we she is yeah she
is um I guess my my first point here is
like it it seems like she made this rule
specifically no one under 16 yeah to
make sure that he's that his son is not
there specifically because she does not
want any vestages of his old wife and
old or El's partner an old uh family to
be there and I think that's incredibly
Petty it's interesting too that she's
forged a relationship with him prior to
the marriage but it seems like she
thinks that by getting married it's
transforming the relationship and now
her his son can be sort of like pushed
out excluded right right so yeah I don't
know of
um most any parents that uh are good
shuing off their children yeah you know
there's two other things in here that I
think are really um worth noting so the
first is she wasn't she wasn't
straightforward about what what what her
real reasoning was I think that's always
a problem when people say something and
it seems like oh you know this is just
about being polite or something like
that and then you get well what's the
real reason what's really driving this
and then they come out and say it
because they didn't get their way the
first time they she should have been
straightforward and said I've got this
issue with you having um your son
because it's a proxy for your exy wife
and I don't want I don't want that
involved in my wedding she shouldn't
have come up with you know um
babysitting or or stuff like that and
then her accusing him of that ever pre
you know prevalent word these days
gaslighting right there's nothing in
here that's remotely like
gaslighting um and she sounds like the
kind of person who uses that term in a
sloppy way to to mean manipulating or
fooling or something like that that but
she's the one who's actually if
anybody's doing gaslighting in a very
broad sense she'd be the one right yeah
it still wouldn't be gaslighting in the
the technical te sense yeah yeah um yeah
this is her not wanting she it seems
like she knows at least at some point
that what her ask is is not an
acceptable ask yeah and she's doing
everything in order to not actually say
that ask
yeah I I think it's interesting too that
he he's really asking am I not seeing
something am I you know did I somehow
cross some ethical line am I the a-hole
when clearly he's he's been very
accommodating right um guess I guess
he's I think he's very confused
considering like his talking about how
she's created an independent
relationship with him as well treating
him nicely yeah so he can't fathom oh
right right potentially why she has such
an aversion to him you know this is
interesting and and I might be reading
way way too much into this I don't think
they should get married to begin with
but if she gave the appearance of
forming a good solid connection with his
son basically to get in good with the
dad and keep everything moving along and
then wants to exclude the son um after
they get married then what's to say she
wouldn't do exactly the same thing to
the
dad you
know it feels like there's there's
cating like trying to create a new
ingroup and out group like the new in
group is the new family the out group is
the old family and so like I'm I'm
trying to like you know I'm going to
grab um I guess uh virtue ethics what
what is it to be an excellent father and
to be an excellent father is probably
not to exclude your children from one of
the largest most important events of
your life yeah
yeah and you could say similarly you
know what does it mean to be a good
spouse to somebody who already has
commitments you marry somebody who has
kids well you know you're you're going
to be involved with those kids just as
much as if they have I don't know like a
business or they have uh pets or
something like that you're you're taking
them on you know I mean there is that
old um proverb when you marry somebody
you marry their family and that's more
about like in-laws and stuff like that
but maybe for you know the Blended
families which are you know very common
these days that's part of it as well I
mean imagine if the bradies you know if
uh what what were the names there was
Carol and what was the guy Brenda no the
remember Steve Steve I I didn't watch so
imagine if they were like well you know
these girls can't be here or these boys
can't be here right or or both both
can't be there in wordss yeah we're
going we're going to start a whole new
life they can all stay with Alice the
housekeeper right you know instead of
the the nine uh slots you know in the
thing you've got uh just Alice with the
kids on one side and then the the you
know the husband and wife having fun off
an aapco or
something all right let's let's go on to
the next one we got another wedding
related one you want to read this one
yeah uh am I the [__] for asking my
sister what the fudge she expected to
happen at
her crap show [__] show of a bachelor
byette
party um so for some reason my uh 32
female male sister um who's all 23 and
her fiance male 25 decide that the very
best way to celebrate before getting
married was to have a joint bachelor
bachelet party at the strip clubs they
also hired a bus limo for every the
evening the aftermath was thus far three
breakups four people dropping out the
wedding party one impending divorce and
one arrest the cleaning bill for the
limo was more than the original rental
free also she was crying to our mom at
dinner the other day and I snorted I
tried not to and I honestly did I was
trying my best to just keep my mouth
shut she asked me what was so funny I
said I wasn't sure what she expected to
happen getting a group of people drunk
using illicit substances and getting
horned up watching exotic dancers she
said that I was an a-hole for judging
her and her friends I said I was wasn't
judging them that literally anyone could
have seen that outcome I told my mom
right my mom told me to apologize
because my sister is having to replace
most of wedding party on the Fly I did
but I still think I'm right this who's
the a-hole yeah this is quite a case um
I mean she's she didn't do anything
other than laugh a little bit at
something that is tough not to laugh at
you know I mean quite a setup to this
right three breakups four people
dropping out of the wedding party one
divorce and one
arrest that's uh quite a toll that this
uh joint Bachelor bachelorette party is
uh taking on the wedding party I mean
was this The Hangover part four what is
this yeah where it's like both genders
yeah yeah
like I just feel
like this might just be opposed like
someone that has just come up with like
the most insane thing if it is true like
yeah
um I know I mean it's not great like her
her laughing but wouldn't call her an
a-hole for it no I mean if you have a
family where
the youngest daughter thinks that this
is a great idea and then the mom doesn't
like step in and say wow this is a
terrible idea what the hell are you
thinking I think it's plausible that the
mom would be you know taking her the
sister's side and saying you know you
shouldn't be laughing at this this is a
serious
matter and it's it's kind of stifling a
laugh herself well I don't know I mean
people have all sorts of misplace
priorities so it seems like the older
sister is like a normal person and I
think a normal person probably would
laugh at this this sort of thing either
that or they'd be like shocked and in
horror um the mom and the younger sister
and the fiance seem like people with
really screwed up priorities you know
um I mean I'd be really bad uh judgment
very go yeah so that I mean I'm laughing
at that one just the idea of it um is is
pretty funny um so yeah let's let's uh
the only other thing is like I can just
remember being like early 20s and this
might have been to that that that preul
developed frontal cortex brain yeah
maybe a good idea but but a party like
that takes a while to plan so it's not
just like impulse control right it's and
and both of them had to be in on it the
yeah uh two
fiances and you know presumably the mom
knew what was going
on you know so the older person should
have given some good counsel or
something like that you you'd hope yeah
um but doesn't mean just because you're
old does not make you automatically wise
no as Aristotle pointed out there's
immaturity in years and there's
immaturity in mind and boy do we have a
lot of people like
that all right should we do the do the
next one yeah so
yes that's you okay uh am I the a-hole
for staying at my daughter's boyfriend's
house now that's with the title you're
like what what how are you getting that
a storm knocked out my 48-year-old
female power Out 3 days ago and it came
back on yesterday when the power went
out I figured my daughter Jen 19 could
stay with her boyfriend Arthur 21 and
I'd stay with my boyfriend 51 male I
asked my boyfriend if I could stay with
him for a couple days and he kept giving
me excuse after excuse so I dropped it I
guess Arthur heard my conversation
because he told me I could stay with him
and his dad too and I accepted long
story short Jen and I got home today and
my boyfriend asked where I stayed I told
him and he flipped out he called me an
a-hole because he didn't like the fact I
was staying with other guys he didn't
care that it was my daughter's boyfriend
and his dad he's not letting it go so I
guess I'm here for my own Peace of Mind
am I the a-hole for staying at my
daughter's boyfriend's house
no yeah definitely not what about the
boy the her boyfriend what do you think
he's a oh oh massive a-hole yeah um like
it feels like he's he's either
controlling or hiding something that he
wouldn't allow her to stay over oh for I
thought of that oh the hiding part yeah
yeah he's being super like Cy at least
from the description here um and so like
who else does he have over at his house
and off often times those people who um
I guess uh are doing something kind of
Nefarious or cheating will um project
project that exactly yeah uh and so
maybe he was cheating and because she
was with another older man of their
similar age that uh he's making that
assumption that she's doing the same
thing that he is yeah I think there's
two other important factors in this one
he had the a chance to have her come
over and he turned her down and uh he
gave excuse after excuse she says right
so it wasn't just no it's not a good
time you know I don't have power
whatever he's he's making up all sorts
of stuff and then the other thing is it
would be it would be different if she
was like you know I just want to go have
a sleepover at my with my daughter's uh
uh boyfriend and and his dad you know
nothing's going on but with this the
power's out so not being able to
differentiate between situations that
are emergency situations essentially and
everyday situations sounds like the
boyfriend has got some perspective
problems here as well right unless he's
like some guy that lives off the grid
and like just thinks that power is not
like an emergency situation I have no
idea when or where this was um it's a
storm a storm knocked out the power so
it's like it wasn't good weather
I know we when I was a kid um I think it
was the winter of 77 we ended up staying
with another
family um in our neighborhood for over a
week because they had a generator and
power was out for you know like a week
we stayed at our place for one day
heating stuff up in the fireplace and
then my dad was like pack all our stuff
up we're we're heading off to the shanes
and and we got the tractor going and um
piled all the things in the back and we
you know like had sleds tied to it as
well and you know we we moved in with
them and it was pretty close quarters
but that's what you do when when things
break down right yeah like I'm trying to
like okay maybe let's let's sing this in
um a cont ethic okay um
uh should your significant other provide
you housing when your housing doesn't
meet its needs for a short period of
time yeah yeah um uh if not should all
them um they automatically not do that
and if that doesn't happen um when
should one get actually angry for them
finding adequate housing in the first
place yeah I was actually considering
and I've never actually thought this out
and I've taught K now for over 20 years
this jealousy aspect
um is can you
universalize this notion of
like almost like ownership you know it's
funny cuz Kant is famous for having
defined marriage as a I don't have the
exact wording but it's like a contract
to use of each other's
bodies which you know okay you kind of
get where he's coming from he's very
into legalistic
stuff there's definitely more to it than
that but like sure is as if you want to
be I guess reductionist and K in yeah um
I mean maybe K isn't really the person
to turn to for this I mean maybe we want
to look at this like in a utilitarian
way and say okay what works out the best
for just about everybody except for
grumpy Gus over here who is yeah I think
utilitarian is a much better framework
so what's what's going to create the
most uh happiness or well-being for the
most people yeah
um he didn't do his bit to like increase
that happiness and it and her subsequent
decision uh decreased his happiness and
apparently hers as well yeah and you
know I think a
utilitarian of certain sorts could even
say you know there's a kind of
commitment that you're making when
you're romantically involved with
somebody that you're you're going to
help take care of them when things get
difficult so if you're not willing to
let somebody stay at your place when the
power is out should you really be
involved with them you know right maybe
they're not relationship material you
know yeah it's like otherwise you're
you're not even a good friend if that if
that's your that's right yeah yeah
doesn't to be
romantic um you know unless you're only
using them for like a sex or something
like that would be like
it then you're not even friends with
benefits you're just benefits right
so yeah all right let's go on let's
check out the next one now this is an
interesting one so um am I the a-hole
for acting Superior at my middle school
reunion um I 23 female in middle school
I was excluded and treated really
harshly by my fellow classmates I lived
in a predominantly Asian area and my and
am Asian myself but I was never seen as
as asan Enough by most of my other peers
because I was chubby and I didn't do
well in school neurode Divergent they
would constantly be passive aggressive
to me and act like I was a pest whenever
I was trying to genuinely be nice so I
started resenting them and hanging out
with other people who actually accepted
me today I changed a lot I lost a ton of
weight after high school and I met
friends with a photographer help me get
a start up with modeling I'm nowhere
near as successful as Naomi Campbell but
I do high fashioned editorial mod
modeling I'm proud of my position I'm
aware that I'm very fortunate to be in
the position that I am in yesterday
night was my middle school reunion I
have a good group of friends I've known
since middle school so we were all
together when we arrived I felt
uncomfortable and only spoke to my group
or the people who didn't treat me like
crap whatever where whenever one of the
people who used to act badly towards me
tried to speak to me I just ignore them
continuing to talk and not looking at
them at all I didn't see any issue they
did the same thing to me but apparently
it irritated one of the dudes this one
posted my low test score to humiliate me
in middle school he came up to me and
was trying to talk to me but I just
ignored him he started telling me
I thought I was better than everyone
else and I was acting like a stuck up
prick I replied that I am better than
everyone else and that's why I have a
more successful career we then had some
back and forth because I mentioned that
he treated me like crap so he couldn't
act entitled to me uh my time or respect
at that point my friends told me to
let's just leave I personally feel like
I personally feel like you dish out what
you get they all did the same stuff to
me in Middle School my friends were all
on my side but some of them felt like I
could have tried to be nice to keep the
peace am I the a-hole what do you think
R um I think there's
a half
aish Behavior there and it's I I don't
actually have a problem with snubbing
people who snubbed you um I I don't
think that you have a duty to talk to
every body at a reunion when you haven't
seen them for a very long time you know
it's it's it's what we could call a
supererogatory Duty right where it's
above and beyond that's a supererogatory
means it means uh above what can be
asked or what can be demanded so it
would have been nice if she would have
buried the hatchet and showed herself as
not still being um in a middle school
mentality but there's no obligation to
do so but
um when the the guy said you're acting
like a stuck up prick and she replies I
am better than everyone else and that's
why I have a more successful career I
think that's crossing the line into a
holer at that point and you know you
could say well she was hurt in the past
you know she's back in a situation where
she's feeling all those feelings from
way back then but you know as an adult
there's different ways of handling that
and she chose to go to the reunion what
did what did she think was going to
happen going to the reunion right so I
don't know I I think she's she's not a
complete a-hole but she's kind of an
a-hole yeah what do you think U well the
first thing this is a middle school
reunion Middle School sucks everyone
that's true
uh hopped up on hormones that they've
never had experienced before like middle
school kids suck they get better they
get each other they bully each other
they're mean to each other yeah um like
just in general Middle School is usually
not the best lot years of one's life um
and so there's everything unless I don't
know exactly how like everyone went to
the same high school after or they
dispersed um I've never gone to a middle
school reunion nor ever heard of a
Middle School reunion but I guess it
must be a thing yeah I'm right there
with you um so like for the context like
this this all seems very Juvenile and um
Middle School mentality and maybe
because you're going back to a middle
school you're you're going back to your
your middle school mannerisms like I
understand like going back and seeing
old friends and kind of slip into Old
mannerisms and old jokes that are
relevant to that particular group um
and so maybe they're just primed yeah a
little bit to be like the
the few bestant pre-teens and teens that
they were at that moment in their life
um would it make a difference if this is
like a 10-year Middle School reunion as
opposed to like a 30-year Middle School
reunion would you would be more willing
to say okay so 10 years after middle
school so eighth eighth grade ends year
around she's 23 so this is definitely
like the 10 year okay yeah yeah
so yeah eighth grade you're like 12 or
13 yeah so this is this is probably her
tenure would you be more willing to cut
her some slack than if she's going to
her 30 year and she would be a oh yeah
okay um she's still
23 um oh I I I agree that she kind of
you know veered a little bit into the
AOL um the other guy seemed to be
um annoyed that she was like not talking
to him but she doesn't exactly owe him
that as you said yeah I don't know there
there's a little ay to go around here
yeah
okay I mean I I'll say this before we
close this one out if you go to a
reunion you really ought to be prepared
to run into people who you probably
didn't like that much I mean unless you
got along with everybody in high school
and you
know maybe there's maybe there's some
sort of moral obligation to try to get
along rather than like rub people's
noses and things but I don't know I mean
I where I went to school everybody got
bullied but there was like the people
who really really badly got bullied and
then there were uh the rest of us so I I
don't presume to speak for the people
who really were terribly traumatized you
know maybe maybe they get to be jerks
you know when they go back daed and
Confused a documentary for you uh my
stuff was before that so it would be
more like um you know some of the movies
in the
80s um where people oh The Breakfast
Club great example you know that was
sort of contemporary with us at the time
by the way it was a total digression my
mom um was a a pretty interesting person
and she actually um had like she took
movies pretty seriously so she saw the
Last Temptation Of Christ when that came
out in the theaters and it was super
controversial said that that restored
her faith in in in Jesus you know um
seeing a a actual like human uh Jesus
who could have sexual fantasies and
stuff like that she'd grown up in the
pratic 2 church where you know Jesus was
this wonderful uh Divine character and
and uh you didn't dare question anything
right yeah but she also saw The
Breakfast Club and we'd seen it my
sister and I and she saw it um I think
she saw it at a friend's house and she
came home and she was in tears and she
said oh I saw The Breakfast Club you
know now I understand how hard it is for
you kids and we were like we're not like
those people in The Breakfast Club you
know we don't even have the same kind of
like clicks that they do you know uh we
call that kind of person sort of like a
whatever Bender was or bendler we call
those guys burnouts you know obviously
we had jocks and nerds and stuff like
that but it was funny to see but you
could you know she would she would watch
those sort of things and and uh popular
culture help helped her kind of process
things
so yeah all right well we we should get
back to looking
we got a really juicy one here yeah
let's go for it am I the a-hole for [__]
shaming a [__] shamer I admit this is
pretty this is petty but some mutual
friends think I'm the a-hole and doesn't
seem to rise to the level of a-hole to
me so another opinion would be helpful I
19-year-old female am not sexually
active by choice not for any moral
reason I just want to focus on
University without extra complications
and I'd rather my first be with somebody
I care about and feel completely
comfortable with guys get weird about it
when sex comes up either they fetishize
it turn it into a challenge or they lose
interest the guys that get all excited
about a zero body count are the worst
and it's my number one dating pet peeve
there's a guy we'll call Bob that hangs
around my friend group because he's one
of the other guys roommate Bob has good
moments but he acts like a major douche
canoe when dating or sex comes up brags
about sleeping with a lot of girls but
also looks down on them for being loose
I try to avoid Bob anyway Bob asked me
out before Thanksgiving break like two
days before that I heard him talking to
one of the guys about a girl he went on
a date with and he said he hit it and
quit it because he doesn't date [__] so
when Bob asked me out I said no thanks
he pressed for a reason and I told him
that I heard him talk about all of his
hookups and I don't date [__] you
should have SE the look at of his face
he said it really wasn't that many and
he was exaggerating a little I'm wife
material so he's not looking to hook up
I said if his body count was over zero
he was too easy to be husband material
Bob lost his crap about it and the
friend group is split some think it's
hilarious and Bob got a taste of his own
medicine others think it was wrong to
[__] shame him even if he is kind of a
bell end I think this is hilarious
myself also I'm expecting British just
with the the the bell end at the end
there yeah yeah well and it said uni too
I I changed that to University so but
yeah what do you what do you make of it
I to me this seems like just applying
standards um
universally yeah um yeah he didn't like
besides the rhyme like the rhyme is fine
like like is is this rubbing it in a
little bit but like it's that is so
harmless um I I don't see anything that
she did here
uh that would cause a group to to split
over well I think that's in part because
a lot of people do have these um rather
double standard ideas about Absolut
sexuality right so it wouldn't be
surprising if some of them were also
some of the girls in the group right and
and I assume that she heard this this
quip that she's now uh modified this on
body if his body count was over zero he
was too easy to be which I assume to be
wife material instead of husband
material yeah yeah um and and you know
turn about as fair play in this regard
um exactly yeah I mean if you're going
to impose these sort of Standards on
women as a man you've got zero cause to
complain if women want to apply those
exact same standards to you you know
what what is this the um the Madonna and
the the charlet I think two archetypes
that um you know at least within our
Western culture that are like you either
want they have the Pure or you want the
you know the someone that's like great
Between the Sheets right y um but uh
then you have this this issue because
neither of these two can meet and then
you're what are you expected to do when
you find a wife um I know yeah he's
definitely the a-hole in this that he he
was had his own standard applied to him
and he was upset by that that means that
you have a double standard I would go so
far as to say the others who think it
was wrong to [__] shame him they're kind
of a-holes
too what do you think about that idea
plausible or implausible um so I'm just
thinking about the idea of like [__]
shaming him in the first place and like
um he he's constantly doing it so that
that is his uh criteria yeah and so if
they accepted that in the past and are
now not accepting it now then they are
also applying the they're being
inconsistent yeah yeah yeah so in that
case I would call them the a-holes if
they were at least agreeing or at least
tacitly agreeing to his statements
beforehand okay I think we have time for
maybe one
more so let's take yeah this short one
I'll I'll just read it real quick and
then see what you think about it am I
the a-hole for calling my friend
neurotypical me 16-year-old female and
my friend 15-year-old female were
hanging out at school we started talking
about this game where the main focus is
socialization she begged me to play it
but I still refuse thankfully she let it
go a few days later the topic comes up
again and I decline once again
explaining it's difficult for me to
approach people and hold conversations
as I struggle a lot with social anxiety
and autism she tells me that it's not
that hard and I just need some
confidence we got into an argument I
told her she doesn't understand because
she's neurotypical and won't know what
it's like to make something clear I know
she's neurotypical because she's gone to
get tested before and hasn't had
anything new come up from what I know
she quickly got angered called me
childish and hasn't spoken to me in two
weeks am I the a-hole what do you think
oh okay um I no she's not the a-hole I
guess what it comes down to no okay in
my opinion so she's saying like I have a
different experience than you and to be
an adult is to understand that people's
experiences are often different yeah I
think there's enough here to have one
a-hole and we can split it between the
two of
them because I think this this idea that
oh you can't possibly know what life is
like for me because I have this label
that I've I've picked up that happens to
be very trendy right now and you you
know person over there who doesn't have
this this other label you can't know my
that's complete nonsense I mean things
like this are are a spectrum and and you
can easily relate to other you can
relate to other people's challenges even
if you don't share exactly what it is
otherwise we couldn't communicate we
couldn't have empathy we couldn't do any
of these sorts of things um now they are
young so maybe we cut him some slack
because of that what do you think yeah
like they're 15 and 16 they're they're
they're filling these things out and
they don't understand like the full you
know experience of life yet like yeah
and they're they're gonna get angry at
certain things they want to be special
and we all want to feel special at
least yeah now um if they were older
like let's say it was 26 and 25 would we
cut them as much slack no
okay then then you're you're stuck in
kind of like a a more black and white
thinking about life and uh exactly yeah
um you can't at all know something oh
was there's um I can't remember the guy
there was some guy who was a um a
Biblical scholar but he was a Muslim he
was practicing
Muslim um and so people were telling him
that uh he couldn't have any right it
ideas about the Bible even though he was
a scholar of it because he didn't
actually follow that as his religion
well that's interesting and so it's like
one can not be part of the group and
also knows a lot about the group it's
like yeah that's what we have like Jane
Goodall as an example or just any sort
of like person that's going to study a
culture you don't have to be a part of
this culture to understand that culture
well definitely helps yeah that's that's
a good point well I think we got a
finish up so do you want to take us out
on a final quote Yeah so uh we leave you
today with the words of Brad Warner even
if the whole universe is nothing but a
bunch of jerks doing all kinds of jerk
type things there is still Liberation
simply not being a
[Music]
jerk